an awesome teacher can leave a lasting
impression on their students every
teacher is unique but when an educator
goes above and beyond to inspire
encourage instill a love of learning and
make the students laugh until they can
hardly breathe they deserve some
recognition if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we're sharing 10 coolest teachers
you wish you have babysitting teacher as
student showed up to class with her baby
because she couldn't afford to leave the
child would consider instead of turning
students in the baby away
this feature welcomed them both into the
classroom later on the baby became upset
and started to cry so the teachers took
matters into his own hands he strapped
the baby to his chest and continued on
with his lecture the mother was able to
focus on learning and the child received
an awesome babysitter for the day pretty
cool right some much-needed
encouragement a reddit user became
depressed and missed numerous days of
school after his father died his
teachers allowed him to make up the
assignments but one teacher named mr.
Barreiro
gave him two college applications to
fill out instead a few months after
graduating the student received a
college acceptance letter in the mail he
didn't intend on going to college but
since mr. Barreiro had gone out of his
way to help him further his education he
decided to accept years later he now has
his master's degree all thanks to one
teacher who cared enough to give him a
head start on a teacher
less than three falling asleep in class
is one of the worst things that can
happen to a student the punishment is
usually severe resulting in detention
and maybe even a trip to the principal's
office but this teacher didn't take it
personal when the student dozed off he
turned this awkward situation into a
funny joke by taking a selfie right next
to the sleeping kid we definitely need
more cool features like this in the
world Rockstar teacher can you imagine
walking into class and seeing your
teacher dress up as a rock star
these students received a private
performance from their teachers who went
all out with the rocker theme complete
with cutoff tea leggings a bandana
around his head and a guitar
we're not sure what songs he serenaded
these lucky students with but we're
pretty sure his performance was
memorable our teacher every day this
teacher arrives to class early to lead
his students a visual masterpiece on the
chalkboard
it's always a different work of art and
sometimes
include an insightful message on this
particular day the teacher drew a bear
along with the caption bears eat a
hundred percent less happy people than
side people don't get eaten be happy for
sure this message put a big smile on all
of his students faces daily inspiration
how amazing would it be to walk into
class each morning and see a
personalized message written just for
you to inspire their students to always
be their best this group of teachers
leaves empowering messages on each
student's death this little push is just
what many students need to get their day
started off on the right foot
playback teacher many students rush to
get to school on time every morning and
many of them have to skip out on
breakfast to make it in on time for
their first class this teacher
definitely understands the struggle of
trying to learn on an empty stomach so
we actually allows the students to cook
up a healthy meal right in the middle of
class hopefully there's more than enough
bacon to go around best homework ever
homework is probably the most dreaded
part of school students get swamped with
so many assignments and it can
definitely become overwhelming but this
teacher took a different approach to
homework that his students truly love
instead of assigning essays or projects
he gave his class 6 homework options
ranging from mastering kungfu to wearing
a fake mustache for 24 hours we're not
sure how this fits into his curriculum
but it sure is hilarious wouldn't you
love to have a teacher like this monster
statue this art teacher and Montana
tossed conventional art projects aside
and gave his students a lesson on
creating massive sculptures the teacher
in his class designs life-size monsters
and place them in wooded areas
throughout the city as long as no one
was completely freaked out when they
came across one of these monsters we
think this art project is a genius idea
how about you the best principal the
days of selling candy for a school
fundraiser are long gone this principal
really wanted to find a way to encourage
students to donate $1 to his fundraising
efforts so she decided to sell them a
piece of taste the students were then
allowed to stick the principle to the
wall using the strip judging by this
picture it looks like his fundraiser was
definitely a success which of these
teachers do you wish you had please as a
comment down below and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up